اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش فيها هذا
المساء
لا لتطبيع العلاقات دمشق تصر على شروطها
وانقره لا تستجيب هل مسار المصالحه يراوح
مكانه ام ستغيره نتائج انتخابات تركيا
[موسيقى]
وحلم اوكرانيا المقاتله امريكيات الصنع اف
16 المفضله باتت اقرب لكييف تورط للناتو
في الصراع ام بدايه تصعيد في سماء القرمه
ونحييكم متابعينا الى نقاشنا الاول جهود
المصالحه بين تركيا وسوريا متواصله بعد
نحو 12 عاما من القطيعه فكل من الجانب
السوري والتركي يحاول اعطاء مسار خريطه
اتصال تتماشى مع اسس احترام السياده
والشرط الرئيسي انهاء الوجود العسكري
التركي لتحقيق التقارب المثمر بين البلدين
وزير الخارجيه فيصل المقداد سمن الجهود
الروسيه المبذوله في سبيل اعاده العلاقات
بين البلدين لكنه اكد مجددا بان دمشق لن
تطبع العلاقات مع تركيا التي تحتل اراضي
في سوريا على حد قوله فبعد تسجيل تقدم في
خريطه التقارب بين البلدين في الاشهر
الماضيه والذي بدا باجتماع وزراء الدفاع
برعايه روسيا التي تحاول لعب دور القيادي
في مسار عوده العلاقات تساؤلات كثيره تطرح
حول شروط كل طرف لضمان عوده العلاقات
للطريق الصحيحه الرئيس السوري بان اي لقاء
مع اردوغان يرتبط بالوصول الى مرحله تكون
تركيا فيها جاهزه بشكل واضح للخروج الكامل
من الاراضي السوريه وهو ما رد عليه
قياديهم بالحزب الحكم في تركيا بان احتمال
حدوث لقاء بين الرئيسين غير وارد حاليا
وسيتضح الامر بعد الانتخابات الرئاسيه
التي يمكن ان تتغير معها سياسه الخارجيه
المتبعه ووفق مراقبين فان انقره تحول
البحث عن بدائل سياسيه عن العمل العسكري
لتحقيق تحالف مع سوريا ضد قوات قصد وهو ما
يضمن لها تثبيت وجودها العسكري في مناطق
خوض التصعي
التقارب التركي السوري بعد 12 سنه من
القطيعه مسار خريطه الاتصال بين تركيا
وسوريا ارتسمت معالمه في الاشهر الماضيه
برعايه روسيه موسكو تحاول لعب دور قيادي
في مسار عوده العلاقات بين البلدين تركيا
اكدت بان تطور العلاقات مرتبطا باتخاذ بعض
الخطوات في العمليه السياسيه من الجانب
السوري اردوغان اكد بانه لا خلاف ابدي في
السياسه ولقائه بالاسد يمكن ان يحصل دمشق
تشترط انهاء الوجود التركي بالاراضي
السوريه لتحقيق تقارب مثمر
اتسمت العلاقات التركيه السوريه بالتوتر
وسط اتهامات متعدده الاطراف
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من دمشق
الكاتب والمحلله السياسي غسان يوسف اهلا
بك من اسطنبول الدكتور مهند حافظ اوغلو
على اكاديمي والباحثه السياسي اهلا بكم
ضيوفي الكرام واسمحوا لي ان ابدا من
اسطنبول معك دكتور مهند دكتور مهند في
الواقع سوريا واضحه ووزير خارجيتها اكد
مجددا على ان اي تطبيع يجب ان يكون اساسه
وخروج كل القوات التركيه من سوريا وانهاء
ما اسماه بالاحتلال التركي للاراضي
السوريه السؤال هو الى اي مدى قادره تركيا
ان تلتزم بذلك بالاشاره خاصه الى مخاوفها
المتعلقه بتامين حدودها الجنوبيه
وجميع المشاهدين والضيف الكريم اذا كانت
سوريا واضحه في هذه الشروط التي بين
المزدوجين نعتبرها في عالم الخيال لا في
عالم الواقع السياسي فان تركيا ليست لديها
شروط تركيا تريد
عمليات عمليات حقيقيه على الميدان تريد
وقائع مجسده تنتهج من خلالها هذه المصالحه
خطوات متقاربه برعايه روسيه وبالتالي
تركيا اكدت وتؤكد والرئيس اردوغان
بتصريحاته قبل يومين يؤكد على انه لا خروج
القوات التركيه من الجغرافيا السوريه
لماذا لان هناك ارتباط تام بين الامن
القومي التركي ووحده الاراضي السوريه مجرد
ان تخرج تركيا من الاراضي السوريه فان ذلك
يعني تهديد المباشر للامن القومي التركي
يعني لماذا قام التركي بكل هذه العمليات
العسكريه ولماذا هي موجوده عسكريا هناك
ايضا اليس لاجل حمايه امنيه القومي في ظل
غياب سيطره النظام السوري على جزء من
الجغرافيا السوريه يعني تركيا عندما تقول
اننا نريد حوارا عمليا واقعيا ولا نريد
شروطا خياليه هذا لانها تدرك تماما حقيقه
الواقع ولكن يبدو ان النظام رؤيه اخرى لا
ادري ان كانت رؤيتهم من ذاته ام هي رؤيه
ايرانيه بلسان سوري في التقارب مع دمشق مع
انقره هذا الامر لا يمكن ان يعول عليه
يعني كلنا نعلم انك تعتذر بانه هذا هذه
الشروط السوريه التي اعتبرتها خياليه وضرب
من الخيال هي بتاثير ايراني
على قناه الشخصيه نعم لان اي تقارب ما بين
دمشق استاذ غسان فقط بخصوص هذه النقطه
لانه حضرتك استاذ غسان تعلم بانه
المعنيون بما يحدث في سوريا هناك جهات عده
ضيف يتحدث عن ايران هل ما تحدثت به سوريا
من وجوب انهاء الاحتلال هو امر سيادي وهذا
ما تتحدث به سوريا الرسميه او هناك
تاثيرات خارجيه تحدد هذا المسار
قال حتى اللاجئين نحن بحاجه الى هؤلاء كيد
عامله فيهم الكثير من اليد العامله لاحظي
ايضا يعني مثلا عندما سالته الى اين
سيعودون قال سنبني لهم مساكن اين ستبني
لهم مساكن في عفرين التي هجرت اه
لها في اعداد في اماكن
اللاجئ السوري يجب
ان يعود الى وطنه الى حيه الى المكان الذي
يسكن فيه هكذا تكون عوده اللاجئين وهكذا
يكون التفاوض بين سوريا وتركيا انا اقول
لك اليوم سوريا جاده في التفاوض اذا كان
هناك انسحاب للاحتلال التركي من الاراضي
السوريه في اجل ما يقوله اردوغان دائما
دقيقه
الارهاب والارهاب وقتل الارهابيه وغير ذلك
وتعالوا نعم تعالوا نتعاون لا يكون هناك
كردي في شمال شرق سوريا ولكن عليك ان تقدم
شيئا ماذا قدمت تركيا منذ التقارب التركي
حتى الان لم تقدم شيء
بصور واللقاءات واريد ان التقي بالرئيس
الاسد اذا كنت ستلتقي الاسد وتقول له انا
لن انسحب من ارضك
اعلم سيلتقي هل نلتقي مع نتني مثلا ونقول
له مبروك عليك الجولان هذا كلام خارج عن
المنطق وهذا هو الكلام الخيالي فعلا
وحضرتك تتحدث
لك
دخلنا في تعقيدات اخرى في الواقع بدانا
نتحدث عن عوده اللاجئين وهو ملف مهم جدا
ولكن دكتور مهند طلبت التعليق تفضل لك
الكلمه
يعني هناك قياس مع الفارق يقول لك نقدم
الجولان لاسرائيل ونقدم الشمال السوري
تركيا هذه قياس مع الفرق ولا يصح اصلا هذا
القياس اولا ثانيا يقول لك تركيا تدعم
داعش وتدعم الارهاب وهي من ادخلت العناصر
الارهابيه الى سوريا يعني ايضا هذا القفز
على الحقيقه المشاهد لم يعد يعني يقتنع
بهذه المقولات التي تصب فقط ربما للخطاب
في الداخل السوري يعني هناك واقع يفرض
نفسه اليس واقعا ومؤكدا بان تركيا تتعرض
للارهاب بسبب عدم سيطره النظام السوري على
الجغرافيا السوريه تركيا تقول لي دمشق
هاتي يدك لنتعاون لنرجع الامور الى ما
كانت عليه قبل 2011 من خلال بس السيطره
ولكن هل تستطيع دمشق ان تقول ان قصد
ارهابيه وتجب محاربتها هذه نقطه اولى يعني
ثانيا يقول لك
الواقعيه وان دمشق واقعيه وتركيا لم تقدم
شان لماذا تقدم تركيا شيئا على اي اساس
يعني ما هو الدافع الذي يوجب على تركيا ان
تقدم ما يجب ان تقدمه لدمشق لكي تستطيع او
لكي تفرض او لكن لكي تذهب دمشق نحو
الواقعيه السياسيه ولكن ليس نحن على اعطاء
ولكن دكتور مهند بهذا التصعيد حتى في
قراءه هذه المواقف من الجانبين نحن في
الواقع وكاننا امام ماضله حقيقيه امام
ماضله
عدم القدره على وجود حل وسط لانك لما تقول
حضرتك دكتور مهند بانه على نظام السوري ان
يسوي وضعيه او ان يدخل في حوار مع اكراد
سوريا في الشمال اكرت سوريا في الشمال
كذلك لهم مطالب هم يطالبون باعتراف بلا
مركزيه في الحكم وكذلك بتقاسم
الثروات بطريقه عادله وكانك تشير الى انه
يجب ان يكون هناك حوار سوري سوري كردي قبل
ان يكون هناك حوار
سوري تركي
هذه مرحله متقدمه استاذه ريم يعني كل ما
هو بعيد عن الامن القومي التركي تركيا لا
يعنيها يتفق النظام مع قسى يكون هناك حكم
ذاتي لهم ولكن بشرط كما اوجب التركيه منذ
سنوات وهي تقول تريد عشرين ميلا عمقا
لامنها القومي او تتفق مع دمشق على اعاده
صياغه بنود اتفاقيه اضنه او باتفاق جديد
يرسم ما هو يعني عملي وواقعي ويطمئن تركيا
لامنها القومي سواء كان ذلك برعايه روسيه
ايرانيه او كان هناك لقاء مباشره ما بين
خارج الدفاع والامن ما بين انقره وادي
دمشق لا يمكن ان نتحدث او ليس ليس تركيا
ليست معنيه فيما هو يجري في الداخل التركي
بقدر ما هي معنيه بان يكون امنها القومي
ضمن
حاجز الامان الذي هو 20 هذا ما تريده
تركيا فقط وضحت نقطه حضرتك استاذ غسان
خلينا نفهم معك ما هي المقاربه السوريه
بخصوص اقراض سوريا في الشمال كيف يمكن
التعامل مع هذا الملف وقد يسبق التعامل
معه التعامل مع الحكومه التركيه
يعني تريد لاحظي مثلا
الامور بالوقائع تركيا تعتبر قصد ارهابيه
سوريا تعتبر جبهه النصره ارهابيه وهي
محميه من تركيا في ادلب
ايضا هناك الكثير ما يسمى الجيش الوطني
يعني اغلبهم مجموعات امكانيه
قاعده تنضوي تحت ما يسمى الجيش الوطني
وكيف هو جيش وطني ويرفع العلم التركي لذلك
نحن اليوم نقول بان المجموعات الارهابيه
المتواجده في ادلب وشمال غرب حلب ما يسمى
الجيش الوطني حراس الدين حزب الاسلامي
التركي الثاني وجنود الشام وهم اغلبهم
الشيشان وغير ذلك هؤلاء هم الارهابيون
بالنسبه لسوريا بالنسبه لشعبنا واخوتنا
الاكراد هي شمال شرق سوريا اعتقد بان
الامور ستتحل داخليا ولكن الموضوع ان هناك
مشروع تركي يسمى الميثاق الملي تصوري
اسمعي هذا الميثاق المنديري الميثاق
المالي يقول بان المنطقه الشماليه من
اللاذقيه وهي محتله من تركيا يسمى جراني
ما زالت محتله من تركيا ويتبع فيها من
يعيش فيها
والمجموعات الصينيه والاوزبكيه والشيشانيه
وغير ذلك هؤلاء جاءوا فرضوا وفي ادلب هناك
اربعه او خمس كرات
اعيش فيها اجانب تهجر اهلها ويستوطنون في
هذه المناطق لم تقم تركيا بالعمل باي شيء
حصل لم تقم بفتحه حسب اتفاق 20 20 ايضا
يقول الميثاق يقول الميثاق المللي بان حلب
وادلب والرقه والحسكه وسليمانيه واربيل
وكركوك كلها اراد عثمانيه ولذلك لاحظ
الرئيس في اثر ماذا قال قال عثمانيه بنكهه
اخوانيه وانا اقول لك هناك مشروع عثماني
ومشروع اخواني وانا اقول لك انا كاتب
ومحلل سياسي ومختص بالشان التركي واخي
مهند وهو سوري اقول لك يا مهند لن ينسحب
اردوكان لان لديه اطماع عثمانيه وانه كان
يناور في الانتخابات فقط وانه لا يريد
اعاده اللاجئين وانه يريد ان يبني حزام
تركماني من شمال اللاذقيه الى شمال غرب
سوريا ويريد ان يهجد الاسرار من مناطقهم
ويقوم ببناء وحدات سكنيه ليسكن منهم
يوالونه ومن هم وعندما يريد ان يحتل هذه
الاراضي يقول تعالوا
اي استفسار وهؤلاء دكتور مهند
افسده على اردوغان هذه الخطه
وكونوا مع تركيا برعايه روسيه ايرانيه لكي
لا تقول ان التركي يتلاعب بنا كونوا مع
روسيا ومع ايران وتعاون مع تركيا وافسدوا
على ارضوان هذه الخطه التي تقولها وتدعيها
ولتعد الجغرافيا السوريه كامله تحت النظام
السوري وانا ذاك سوف تعود الامور الى ما
كانت عليه سابقا يعني تركيا قبل 2011 لم
تدخل ولا جنديا تركيا ولا تدخل مترا واحدا
هذا الكلام هذا الادعاء غير مدعوما
بالواقع وعلى العكس الواقع يفنده والواقع
يقول ان تركيا من مصلحتها من مصلحه تركيا
انظر الى الكلام من مصلحه تركيا الحفاظ
على وحده الاراضي السوريه وعدم تقسيمها
الى حكم ذاتي لانفصاليين الاكراد او الى
غيرهم وبالتالي هذا الواقع ما تريده تركيا
ببساطه يعني ابسط من هذا لا يوجد تركيا
تقول
لاعين دمشق على بسط سيطرتها على كامل
الحدود السوريه ولتبقى الجغرافيا السوريه
كتله واحده من دون تقسيم ولكن
حضرتك لما تقول افسدوا على اردوغان مخططه
العثماني وتعاونوا مع الايرانيين
والروسيين
كيف
عسكريا تتحدث
طبعا عسكريا ميدانيا يعني انا عندما اقول
افسده على الرئيس اردوغان هذه الخطه التي
يدعيها ضيفك انا لا اقول اردوغان او يريد
هذا الحلم اصلا غير موجود تركيا تركيا
تركيا هناك دوله ذات مؤسسات وبالتالي ليس
الرئيس اردوغان من يقود هذه الدوله بمفرده
وهو منضبط بما تقول به دولته وبالتالي
الواقع والميدان هو من يحكم اي مسار في
مستقبل الايام مع دمشق اذا ما بقيت دمشق
مصره على هذا الامر اولا سوف تحرج موسكو
امام انقره ثانيه لن يكون هناك تحرك في
الميدان على الواقع في الجغرافيا السوريه
وسوف قال وضع على ما هو عليه التعريف سريع
يقول لك ان تركيا تدعم الارهابيين تركيا
هي من تحارب الارهاب بكل اشكاله وبكل
علواني اصاله عن نفسها وبالنيابه عن
النظام السوري الذي فقد سطرته على اكثر من
هو لا يتحدث بالمنطلق تحليل هو يتحدث على
فكره هناك تقارير وتقارير حتى بستها جهات
روسيه ليست جهات سوريه بس التقارير وتحدثت
عن انه في مرحله من المراحل نحن لا نتحدث
عن الامس او قبل امس او قبل اسبوع نتحدث
في بدايه الازمه السوريه فتحت تركيا
ابوابها وكان هناك
بصور الاقمار الصناعيه دخول افواج قيل
فيما بعد بانها تنتمي لجبهه النصره وتنتمي
لداعش وفتحت تركيا مستشفياتها لمداوات
وفيما بعد طبعا الموضوع كان محل نقاش من
جهه عده
يعني استاذه ريم هذا الكلام يعني اولا
علينا ان نفرق ما بين مرحلتين اساسيتين
المرحله الاولى منذ 2011 وحتى
نهايه سته عشر او بدايه 2017 هذه مرحله
اولى كان هناك دعما اقليميا كبيرا ودوليا
للمعارضه السوريه في تنفيذ ما تريد ان تصل
اليه لكن منذ 2017 وبسبب غياب الدور
السياسي لمعارضه السوريه ولاسباب متعدده
اصبح هناك عوده او انعطافه في الكثير من
المواقف الاقليميه وكذلك تركيا مؤخرا
ارادت ان تلتفت الى الداخل التركي لان
الحكم الدوليه التي تمر بها المنطقه بشكل
خاص والعالم بشكل عام يفرض على تركيا نوع
من هذا نوع من النوع من السياسات ولكن لا
يمكن ان نقول بان تركيا تقوم بدعم الارهاب
كيف وهي يعني هي من قتلت رئيس رئيس زعيم
تنظيم داعش في
منذ ايام قليله هي من لديه عمليات يوميه
في الداخل التركي ضد داعش هي من تحارب قصد
اولئك الارهابيين ومن خلفهم من الفيكيه
الذي الذين يحاولون اقتطاع جزء من
الجغرافيا السوريه فيما يتعلق لكي لا يقول
لي فيما يتعلق
في ادلب وجبه النصره هناك حاضنه شعبيه
تريدهم تركيا لا تستطيع ان تفرض سيطرتها
او رؤيتها على تلك المنطقه باي حال من
الاحوال تركيا وتقولها للبنت العريض للمره
المليون تريد فقط عشرين ميلا امنا وبعد
ذلك لن يفعل نظام السوري
خلينا فقط ننتقل لدماج استاذ غسان تطلب
التعليق تفضل
يعني انا اريد ان اذكر بانه عندما سقطت
الباغوت كانت السيارات ستستخدمها داعش
تركيا الاسلحه تركيه الالبسه تركيا
الاطعمه التركيه الادويه تركيه كل شيء
تركي الاذاعي يعني داعي صناعه تركيا جبهه
النصر اليوم يقول لك الشعب اذا كانت تركيا
تقول بان جثث اخرى ارهابيه لماذا لا تحارب
جبهه النصر لماذا لا تنهي جبهه النصره اذا
كان يريد من سوريا خطوه طيب ما هي الخطوه
اذا كان اردوغان يقول على السي انا لن
ننسحب ما هي يعني كيف كيف نقابله بعضهم قد
يقول البعض والكلام موجه للضيفين دكتور
دكتور مهند
استذكار التاريخ واستذكار مراحل قد يؤذن
امكانيه وجود حل اليوم هناك امر واقع
وهناك مسار سياسي يطمح الطرفان للتقارب
طيب هل يمكن وهنا سؤال لك دكتور مهند هل
هناك
تغيير في سياسه تركيا الخارجيه بين خارجيه
اردوغان وخارجيه المعارضه
طبعا في حال فازت المعارضه بالرئاسه سوف
يكون هناك تغييرا جذريا ليس فقط متعلق
بالعلاقات مع سوريا بل مع المحيط العربي
بل مع دول العالم ومنها استعداء روسيا
بشكل مباشر ولكن اذا ما كان الرئيس
اردوغان هو الفائز وهو الرئيس الثالث عشر
للجمهوريه التركيه فان هناك صحيح اعاده
ترتيب للاوراق في الخارجيه التركيه سوف
يكون انفتاحا كبيرا اكثر مما هو عليه الان
مع الدول العربيه ومع اسيا الوسطى ولكن
الرئيس حددها بشكل واضح وجلي ان الانسحاب
التركي القوات التركيه من الشمال السوري
والوضع الراهن الميداني على ما هو عليه
هذا غير وارد متى ما تغير ومتى ما كانت
هناك خطوات عمليه تغير الواقع الميداني
انا ذاك يناقش الامر لاحقا يعود بخارجيه
ولكن بالنسبه لخارجيه المعارضه مع الاشاره
الى ان المعارضه كانت عدت معنا استاذ غسان
طيب اتفضل لانه الصوره كانت
مائله فتفضل اتفضل استاذ غسان سؤال بس
السؤال
عدت لك من جديد للحديث على مقاربه على حل
وسط في الواقع يمكن التغاظي من خلاله على
التاريخ وامكانيه وجود خط وسط بين الطرفين
الخط الوسط يكون بين الطرفين الاتفاق على
الانسحاب تدريجي للقوات التركيه
اتفاق على
القضاء على المجموعات الارهابيه على ترحيل
المقاتلين الاجانب التي ادخلتهم
في قرى يعني هاجر اهلها منها واصبحت هناك
احياء صينيه وقرى صينيه وغير ذلك في جسر
وفي ادلب وفي غيرها بالنسبه عندما تنتهي
سوريا من الاحتلال التركي وتنتهي من
المجموعات الارهابيه
وننتقل الى المنطقه الشرقيه ويكون هناك
اتفاق سوري تركي روسي ايراني امريكي على
ان يكون هناك وضع يعني لحل ميلياب فسد
وانسحاب الاحتلال الامريكي اما ان تقول لي
لان سوريا تواجه الولايات المتحده من اجل
العيون تركيه فتفضل انت واجه الولايات
المتحده التي تحتل وتنهب نفسنا وتنهب
قمحنا ونحن نعتبره احتلال امريكي لا
تريدون ان تكونوا احتلالا لعامرين
دكتور مهند ليست معنيه بمحاربه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تركيا مع انيابها
القومي فقط وتقول لدمشق تعالي لنتعاون
لضبط الموقف الميداني ولكن هذه الشروط مره
اخرى الغير واقعيه من قبل دمشق هذا لا
يجدي نفعا يا استاذ هذا لن يجدي نفعا هذا
فقط
حضرتك ابن الحسكه لانك دائما كانت الدوله
السوريه هي التي
تضبط الحين اي يعني اختراق للحدود والتزمت
سوريا باتفاقيه اضنهم من انقلب على
اتفاقيه اضنه هي ترفيه ومن نجعل الالغام
هي تركيه وما فتح الحدود الارهابيين هي
تركيا واماني يدعم المجموعات الارهابيه
التركيه ومن يحتل الاراضي السوريه هي
تركيا ومن يحاول ان
يكون عدو حقيقي في شمال سوريا ويقول هؤلاء
الاكراد يعني هم اعدائي هي تركيا تركيا
تريد
اخيرا معك دكتور مهند طيب تجد الذبائع فقط
لاحتلال وضحت هذه النقطه اختم باختصار معك
دكتور مهند بتعليق اخير حول هذه النقطه
يعني هل هل كانت تركيا لتذهب او تدخل
جنديا تركيا واحدا او شبرا واحده في
الاراضي السوريه وتخترق
وتخرق اتفاقيه اضنه لولا هذا الارهاب
الموجود في الشمال السوري لولا هذا الوضع
السياسي والميداني في سوريا بشكل عام يعني
لماذا لم تدخل تركيا قبل 2011
الاراضي السوريه هل هي بحاجه الى جغرافيا
هل هي بحاجه الى بشر غير صحيح الامر منوط
وبشكل اساسي فقط وفقد بالامان بالامان
وبالامن فيما يتعلق بالحدود الطويله التي
تجتاز 1910 كيلو متر على هذا تركيا لم
تخرق اتفاق اضنه بل تركيا تريد ان تعدل
هذا الاتفاق للحمايه هو في كل الحالات
والحفاظ على وحده الاراضي هو في كل
الحالات اولا قد يكون هذا الموضوع مؤجل
لما بعد الانتخابات التركيه قد نفهم اكثر
بعض
الانتخابات التركيه كيف ستكون سياسه
الخارجيه فيما يتعلق بهذه النقطه وثانيا
في الواقع النقاش اليوم افهمنا نحن
كمتابعين حساسيه
العقيدات الموضوع ولماذا هذا التقارب يبدو
بارد في هذه المرحله بعد كميه التصريحات
التي تابعناها من الطرفين الموضوع الاكيد
بانه سيبقى للمتابعه ساكتفي معكم بهذا
القدر اود شكركم يا جزيل الشكر على
المشاركه من دمشق الكاتب والمحلله سياسي
غسان يوسف ومن اسطنبول دكتور مهند حافظ
اوغلو البحث السياسي شكرا لكما
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات